on peut savoir pourquoi tu t'es battu et
que ce flic mais comment tu es d'accord
alors qu'est ce que tu faisais dans cet
hôtel charles vacances en vacances de
ton père
je veux pas regarder la route un peu
pourquoi t'as pas pris l'autoroute j'ai
un rendez vous aux gens tiémoko moi
c'est olga tu crois vraiment à l'âge
pour adopter un enfant mais qui te parle
d' adopter
papa il en dit quoi ton père je parle
père jacques
c'est pour moi l'ambulance attention les
servantes salines pas manqué de
présenter moko salue aujourd'hui si t'as
qu'à l'appeler pp ça lui fera les pieds
je pense que je suis aussi ces quelques
jours tu caches ta mère tu remarqueras
que le pose pas de questions il manque
juste combien de temps tu admires
franchement comment tu le trouves fait
des trucs bizarres
maintenant il serait tout seul vous et
trans en tournant quand même pas lui
reprocher de s'être calmés quand même
d'écouter que le croisic genre hip est
ou non au champion c'est pas très jeunes
en ont mais c'est le boucher ça nous
rend populaire
tu vois le plus important champignons
c'est le coin pique nique et nous avons
fort c'est beau la nature
darty pourquoi tu lui donnes ma tartine
takkal leur faire une autre etc à quel
âge
j'aimerais bien finir ton kiwi cet
enfant doit être rapatrié à la frontière
avec sa mère il me restait quelques noms
de juifs ça vous intéresse
le premier qui s'approche du bois etc ou
arles mois plus tôt de la fille des
champignons pollue tout mon genre c'est
quoi ton genre il fallait exceptionnel